DOES THAT IT TELL US ABOUT THE
FUTURE?
PEDRO GONZALES JOINS US TONIGHT.
HOW DO YOU INTERPRET THIS?
I KNOW IT'S ONLY A FEW DAYS AGO
BUT WHAT YOU MAKE OF IT?
>> GIBBONS IN FLORIDA DON'T VOT
THE SAME WAY AS MEXICANS IN
CALIFORNIA WHAT WE CAN SAY IS
REPUBLICANS IMPROVED IN SOME
PLACES, BUT REPUBLICANS STILL
SEEM TO MAINTAIN A HOLD OF A
MAJORITY OF LATINO SUPPORT
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
THESE PEOPLE ARE PERSUADABLE,
THEY CAN REMOVE.
WHAT WAS THE GOP GROUND GAME
AHEAD OF MIDTERMS?
DEMOCRATS DO OUTREACH IN KEY
PLACES, THEY SPEND MILLIONS
REWRITING VOTING RULES AND
REGULATIONS IN THEIR FAVOR.
THE PRIORITY ON THE OTHER HAND
ARE THE POLITICAL MACHINE AROUN
KEVIN McCARTHY WAS TO TARGET
AMERICA FIRST CANDIDATE LIKE JO
KENT AND WASHINGTON AND ANTHONY
SABATINI IN FLORIDA, BECAUSE
THEY WERE VIEWED AS THREATS TO
HIS POWER.
WHAT WAS THE GOP VISION AND
PROMISED TO AMERICANS?
KEVIN McCARTHY SAID
ENTITLEMENT REFORM, CUTS TO
SOCIAL SECURITY AND MEDICARE
WOULD BE A TOP GOP PRIORITY
AFTER MIDTERMS.
ALSO ACQUIRES GETTING ANOTHER
$50 BILLION FOR UKRAINE BY
JANUARY.
SO WE CUT GRANDMA'S SOCIAL
SECURITY CHECK AND WE MAIL IT T
ZELENSKYY.
IT'S NOT HARD TO SEE WHY THEY
WERE UNDERWHELMING WITH VOTERS
WHEN YOU HAVE THIS KIND OF
LEADERSHIP.
THIS IS ALSO WHY I AM NOT
PESSIMISTIC BECAUSE WHEN YOU
HAVE WASHINGTON GENERALS LIKE
THIS RUNNING THE PARTY, YOU
CAN'T REALLY SAY THAT WE BEGIN
TO FIGHT.
>> I THINK THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT
GREAT IF YOU WERE GOING TO MAKE
THIS IS A LONG CONVERSATION AND
I HOPE YOU COME BACK FOR ANOTHE
HOUR.
IF YOU COULD DISTILL THE MESSAG
THAT WORKS, NOT DESTITUTE LATIN
VOTERS, BUT ANY BOATER, WHAT
WOULD IT BE?
>> THAT AMERICA IS NOT A BIZARRE
, IT'S NOT AN OPEN AIR
MARKET PLACE FOR THE WORLD TO
PLUNDER.
IT IS HOME TO A REAL PEOPLE.
IT IS A HOME THAT THAT IT'S A
HOME TO A REAL FLESH AND BLOOD
PEOPLE AND THAT MEANS WE HAVE A
OBLIGATION TO KEEP OUR
COMMUNITIES SAFE.
WE HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO SECURE
OUR BORDER.
HOW THEY ARE FILLED ON CRIME BU
TO ACTUALLY DO SOMETHING AND
POST ELECTIONS INSTEAD OF JUST
ADOPTING THE DEMOCRATIC POLICIE
ON AND THEN REFRAMING THEM AS
FISCALLY CONSERVATIVE OR AMERIC
FIRST, WHICH IS WHAT THE GOP HA
BEEN HISTORICALLY.
HOW ABOUT BEING AN ANTIWAR PART
OR AN ANTI- NUCLEAR.
THE REASON THEY COULD TALK ABOU
THIS APART IS BECAUSE THE PARTY
LEADERSHIP IS, BUT THE THING
ABOUT WAR IN UKRAINE ENERGY CAN
CONNECTED TO EVERYTHING FROM TH
COST OF FUEL IN YORK TO THE
RISING COST OF FOOD ON YOUR.
>> I THINK YOU ARE EXACTLY RIGHT